ماخفش عليك يا ابني انت حالتك صعبه خالص
لكن من حسن حظك انك جت في الوقت المناسب
يعني ممكن اك يا دكتور طبعا بكل بساطه
استنى ح خطيره
جدا شوف يا
بص عايز تقول ورايا انا مش قصير اع انا
طويل وه انا مش قصير اع انا طويل واحد
ساكت ليه يا ابني انت ما انتش عايز تطل
عايز يا دكتور طب قول انا مش قصير قزع انا
طويل و انا مش قصير قزع انا طويل ودما انا
مش قصير قزع انا طويل واحه شف ولت 5 سم
دلوقتي عاوزك تستمر على حالتك ثلاث شهور
وانت بتاكل وانت بتشهر وانت ماشي وانت ناي
وبعد لاث شهور تجيي هنا مره تانيه عشان
اشوفك ا
سلام سلام عليك وعليكم السلام انت بتطردني
ها انت
بتطردني انت
ضح انت ازاي ويني ازاي كمان انت ليه انت
انت يديكي انت صديقي انت انيس الفيقي ش يا
دكتور ابنك تع تبان يا حاج لا مش تعبان يا
دكتور لا ابنك مجنون يا حاج شفعك يا دكتور
مافيش حاجه اسمها الكلام ده ابني مش مجنون
ابنك مجنون يا حج وانا اللي عارف دهح من
ابني مش
مجنون ابن في متهى
الع
بمين
ع احلى حاجه فيك ايه تساوي عين
بتيجي وده اللي تتساوي
[موسيقى]
بيه
الله هوا ان شا الله د عل الحب الله
هتلاقي عط
[موسيقى]
بنتق طب
يلا
هاي ا مساء الخير مساء الخير ازيكم
النهارده عاملين ايه ا ممكن اشوف ايدين
الناس اللي عجبها الفيديو ده ما شاء الله
ما شاء الله اوكي
ا انا الفيديو ده من اكثر الحاجات اللي
ضحكتني في حياتي كلها وفاكره كويس قوي
اليوم اللي انا كنت فيه في في
السينما وشفت البارت بتاع طب يلا كده
وضحكت واتبهدلت ضحك والناس كلها في
السينما اتفرجت عليا طلعوني بره يعني ا بس
هو الحلو ما بيكملش وزي ما الناس بتقول في
حاجه اسمها هم بيضحك وهم
بيبكي السينز دي قد ما هي مضحكه جدا
وبتضحكي انا ولسه بتضحكني لحد النهارده قد
ما هي بتعكس عيب من اصعب واكبر العيوب
اللي في
مجتمعنا وهي الطريقه اللي احنا بنشوف بيه
المعرض النفسي والطبيب النفسي والمريض
النفسي واي حاجه فيها كلمه النفسي في
الاخر تحس الموضوع كان عادي وفجاه
قخ نفسي
نفسي اوكي بس قبل ما ادخل في هذا الموضوع
المتعجرف البرجوازي الحاد اعرفكم عن نفسي
الاول انا اسمي ايه ناصر وانا مش موجوده
النهارده اكلمكم عن هدف وصلته بعد كفاح
سنين مره ولا ولا حاجه حققتها ولا انجزتها
مش انا خالص هذا الشخص انا هنا بس كمرسل
او ماسنجر وحد نفسه يوصل كلمه لاكبر عدد
من الناس كلمه يفهموها اه لكن يحسو
اكترر ما فيش حاجه في الدنيا كلها ممكن
تكون اصعب من ان انت تواجه مرض نفسي مرض
ما بينك وما بين مخك ما بينك وما بين
افكارك اعصابك اللي بيحركك ككل اللي
بياثروا على جسمك بياثروا على
حياتك عايزاك تتخيل كده معايا لو في يوم
قرر مخك ده انه يسيبك ماليش
دعوه او قرر مثلا الاوحش يقلب ضدك ناكد
عليك عشتك تتبقى عامل ازاي شكلك ازاي شكلك
ازاي مع صحابك شكلك ازاي في شغلك شكلك
ازاي في دراستك هتبقى شكلك ككل ايه
تصرفاتك شكلها ازاي من غير مخك
طيب احنا بقى كناس كمجتمع كافك امتى هنشوف
المرض النفسي صح ونفهمه صح نديك صح وامت
هنطلع من دايره الخوف من المجهول ده ده
هيحصل
امتى طبعا انا من كام سنه كده ماكانش ده
تفكيري خالص بسال نفسي الاسئله الكبيره دي
ولا ل في الحاجات المجعلصه التقيله دي
خالص بالعكس كائن طبيعي جدا بعيش حياه
عاديه
جدا لحد ما حياتي العاديه جدا دي عاشتني
قصص مع اقرب الناس ل غيرت بقى مفهومي
تماما عن كل حاجه واي
حاجه والناس اللي انا موجوده الناس اللي
انا هحكيلكم قصتهم دول اللي هم اقرب الناس
ل انا هنا عشان اوصل رسالتهم دي وغالبا
غالبا بعد ما اوصلها هكون وصلت رسائل ناس
تانيه كتير قوي معايا فخلي ادخل في
الموضوع واحكي لكم قصه قصه دي حقيقيه قصه
اثنين صحابي انا ثالته اثنين اوكي احنا
الثلاثه حياتنا ثلاث ربع الوقت مع بعض
بالرغم ان احنا بنذاكر حاجات مختلفه في
كليات مختلفه انما احنا كنا على طول مع
بعض بناكل مع بعض بنخرج مع بعض شويه
مذاكره للاسف الشديد جدا وبعدين نخرج مع
بعض ونبسط مع بعض وشويه مذاكره للاسف
الشديد جدا
ا انا هسمي هسمي الاتنين صحابي دول عشان
ما تتلخبطش اكس وواي اوكي اكس وواي دول
الاتنين كانوا اقرب لبعض عن انا معاهم
يعني اكس وواي هم على طول سند بعض في
الحياه بيكملوا بعض برغم ان هم مختلفين
جدا اكس وواي بما ان هم كانوا سند بعض
يعني مثلا تحصل حاجه زي انه اكس في في
خناقه مثلا هتلاقي واي على طول رافع سماع
التليفون في ساعتها اطلع لي بره انت اجننت
ولا ايه تتخنق مع صاحبتي لا لا انا اللي
هقف اوعى تقرب من صاحبتي
اوعى كانوا قريبين لبعض جدا يعني فيهم
المعنى الحقيقي للصداقه وطبعا انا معاه
انا برض المعنى الحقيقي الصداقه ما
تنسونيش فحياتنا حلوه جدا زي ما
بحكيلكم لحد ما جت بقى ايام سودا كحل طينه
طينه ايام طينا
اكس اللي هي اكس تدرس هندسه بتدرس فنون
جميله اتفقنا اوكي اكس اللي بتدرس هندسه
ابتدت واحده واحده تتغير تتحول لشخص تاني
خالص ما
نعرفوش ابتدت تبقى حزينه جدا جدا كانها
شايله حاجه حمل كده حزن فظيع عياط هستيري
صحيح الدنيا كانت كلها متحده على الانهيار
فجاه زي ما هي بتحد على الانهيار كده
معانا كتير انما الحزن اللي كان عند اكس
ده كان اكبر بكتير كتير قوي من حاجه زي
كده اصعب اكس ابتدت واحده واحده كده تفقد
التركيز وبما ان هي بتدرس مهندسه وكانت
متفوقه ففقدان التركيز ده بان على طول في
المذاكره كانت الحاجات اللي بالنسبه لها
سهله فجاه بقت راكت ساينس مش عارفه تعمل
حاجه شويه وقمت شايله السمستر
كمان لاحظنا حاجه انيه انها بقت ابطا
مشيتها ابطا ردت فعلها على الحاجات ابطا
كلامها
ابطا بقت شخص
تاني انا وواي في الوقت ده وعيله اكس
حسينا انه في مشكله والمشكله دي مش حاجه
عضويه دفنت لي حاجه نفسيه ومقتنعين انها
المفروض تعمل سر تروح للدكتور وتشوف فيه
ايه وراحت فعلا الدكتور شافت فيه ايه
وعرفت ان اللي عندها ده اكتئاب
حاد والاكتئاب مش ان انت يعني زعلان يا
عيني او الدنيا جايه عليك شويه
بس لا الاكتئاب اثقل من كده اصعب من كده
بكتير واكبر من كده بكتير قوي زي ما بصف
لكم كده اعراضه كمان صعبه
جدا يعني مثلا منظمه السحه العالميه او
ويشن بتقوللك ان في فوق ال
350 مليون بني ادم في السنه في العالم
بيعاني من الاكتئاب 350 مليون بني ادم
ودول الجنوس بس يعني دول اللي فعلا راحوا
لدكتور وحاولوا يتع وحاولوا يحل المشكله
بس ما بالك بقى بالعدد الرهيب اللي مستخبي
ولسه لحد دلوقتي ما قالش
حاجه منظمه الصحه العالميه برضو بتقول
وبتتوجع ان في خلال 15 سنه من دلوقتي
هيبقى الايد اول سبب لبتي في العالم
الايدز وبعده على طول البشن البشن هيبقى
تاني سبب للاعاقه في
العالم فكس بالاكتئاب
ده ابتدت توصف بقى هي حاسه
بايه بتقولك في غيوم كبيره جوه دماغي انا
مش عارفه اتعامل منها غيوم غامقه كده
وكبيره
قوي كان بتحاول على قد ما تقدر انها تتجنب
الاشخاص وتقولك انا مش عارفه اهرب من
دماغي هو انا ههرب من دماغي دي اروح فين
دماغي هرب منها ارح
فين
بس فضلت اكس بقى عندها مشكله واحده اصعب
من كل المشاكل دي وهي الناس الناس هتقول
ايه هي الناس بتعملي كده ليه الناس اللي
هم ابعد شويه
من بتاعتها اللي هي انا وواي وصحابها
القريبين قوي عيلتها لا الدايره الا اوسع
بقى دول كانوا بيتعاملوا ازاي غيروا
عليها يكوش معاها يخافوا منها مثلا وفي
بقى افخم نوع افخم نوع من الناس افخم نوع
ده شكله حضرتك بيبقى كده بالظبط يا اكس
مالك في ايه في ايه فكي كده شويه ودلعي
نفسك مش معقول يعني حابي تغيري الجول يا
شيخه تيجي نروح السينما ها ايه رايك يا
اكس نروح
السينما والله طب دي حاجه جميله جدا فيفهم
افهم كمان من ده يقول لك ايه بقى بص عشان
ده النوع
العبقري حاولي
تفرحي والله
العظيم بجد ايه العبقريه دي معقوله طب ليه
ماحدش فكر بالعبقري دي مثلا انه يكلم حد
زي روبين ويليمز الله يرحمه بقى فينسون
فانجو مثلا صلاح جاهين مثلا دي ناس برض
سلبريتي كانوا بعنوا من الاكتئاب بس هم
سلبريتي السبرتي حضرتك بنبص لهم
كده لكن اشخاص زينا عاديين عندهم اكتئاب
او مرض نفسي لا لا لا لا حول ولا قوه الا
بالله مالش
دعو
اوكي المهم ان اكس بعيدا بقى عن الناس
بعتها وبي وانا وقفتنا جنبها خليتها تدخل
سرك تتعالج تاخد ماديسن تحاول وتقاوم
وتحاول وتقاوم وقعد اربع سنين بتتعالج
واتخرجت واشتغلت في شركه بتحبها واتبت
وبقت شخص كمان احسن عن ما قبل ما كانت
مريض
بجد بقت احسن كتير قوي قبل ما كانت عيانه
اصلا حلوه القصه
عجبتكم بس انا نسيت ازود لكم حاجه بس مهمه
جدا وهي حاجه عن
واي واي الشخص اللي هو ضهر اكس على طول
سند اكس على طول واي اللي هي كان فيها
كميه سلام
نفسي مش طبيعي الناس بتروحلها بس عشان
السلام النفسي اللي عندها دي حلاله العقد
والمشاكل واي واي اللي بتدرس فنون جميله
واي كانت طول الوقت ده وبعده بتعاني من
جنيز انيتي ديسوردر او اضطراب القلق العام
اللي هو نوع من اضطرابات القلق وعلى فكره
اضطرابات القلق دي اكتر مرض نفسي انتشارا
في العالم لدرجه ان انا مش عارفه اجيب له
رقم يعني ككل لان للث الناس بس اللي في
العالم دول للتهم بس اللي
بيتعلم التلت بس انا عندي ارقام م زي ان
في امريكا مثلا مليون شخص عنده نوع من
انواع في انجلترا في 8 مليون شخص ارقام
كانها صغيره يعني بس هي ارقام كبيره
جدا دول برض فيهم على فكره الوسواس
القاهري مثلا الفوبيا
مثلا او حد بيجيله حاجه
اسمها اطراب الاجتماعي حد في وسط الناس
بيبقى قلقان
او حد حصل معاه موقف بشع في حياته من
ساعتها هو مش نفس الشخص خلاص عنده توتر
زياده واي زي اي حد تاني عنده مشكله جلاز
انزايتي
ديسوردر كان تعبها بياثر عليها جسديا معنى
ان
الهضم مش مظبوط صداع مزمن ضربات قلب سريعه
جدا وحاجات تانيه كتير من اعراض الجسديه
اللي بتاثر علينا بقى في حياتنا اليوميه
من واي بتوصف لك ان هي اصعب فتره عليها
بتكون الفتره اللي قبل النوم واللي اول ما
تصحى قبل النوم اللي هي بتكون انت ودماغك
لوحدك خالص دماغك تسلمك بقى والفتره اللي
اول ما
تصحى قبل النوم مثلا تيجي فكره قلقها تخطر
على بالها تقعد الفكره دي تكرر في نفسها
تكرر في نفسها تكرر في نفسها مش اقل من
100 مره من غير مبالغ فكره اللي القاها دي
سيطر عليها تماما توصلها لحد سيناريو
مستحيل انه ممكن يحصل فالسيناريو ده ينتج
عن بانك اتاك او نوبات
ذعر نفس بقى يبتدي يروح خالص يبتدي الهارت
ريت يعلى جدا جدا جدا وتدي بقى تفصل من
الدنيا
تماما وبعدين تهد البانك اتاك تنام تصحى
تقاوم بدايه قلق يوم جديد بدايه قلق يوم
جديد وتنزل تساعد بقى اكس تشوف مشكلتها
ايه وفي وانا وتشوف مشاكل الناس ايه تحلها
ترجع تحارب نفس الحرب تاني تنام تصحى تحار
نفس الحرب تاني
وهكذا فضلت واي برض شوف سبحان الله
مشكلتها هي الناس الناس بتعملها ازاي
الشغل مثلا احنا قلنا واي بتدرس فنون
جميله فهي بترس شغل مثلا يشوفوا لوحه قبل
ما يعرفوا انها عينه طبعا الله اه ايه ده
ايه ده ايه ده ايه الحلاوه دي يا واي مش
معقول الجميل لا لا
عبقريه طيب بعد ما عرفوا بقى عفوا ان في
مشكله مش عارف مش حاسسها قوي يعني انت
تعبانه يا واي تعبانه طب ما ترتاحي شويه
حاولي ترتاحي
شويه او في نوع تاني مثلا ايه ياي في ايه
في ايه ما كلنا عندنا ستس يعني بلاش دلع
بقى بلاش
دلع
واي واكس الاتنين اتع خفوا وبقوا دلوقتي
لما تشوفهم وتكلم مه مستحيل تتوقع ان
الناس دي كانت في يوم من الايام عندها مرض
نفسي وتغلبت
عليه الاتنين بقى تاثيرهم على المجتمع
الصغير اللي معاه ده قوي جدا
جدا وبياثر فيهم جدا الناس بتاثر في
المجتمع اللي حواليها دي بطريقه قويه جدا
وهم ناجحين عمليا كمان
جدا وانا مبسوطه جدا وفخوره جدا ان دول
صحابي وفخوره جدا ان انا واقفه النهارده
بحكي قصه اكس وواي
صحابي انما انا مش مش فخوره ابدا ان انا
لسه مضطره لحد النهارده ان انا اسميهم اكس
وواي واخليهم انونس واحاول اخبيهم من
مجتمع ما بيشوفش اي امراض تانيه غير الكان
او القلب او الكبد او
الكلى او اي مرض عضوي مع ان انت من غير
مخرج ده ما تفهمش المرض العضوي اصلا
ماوش انا هنا كسنجر
النهارده نفسي بس ان الناس تبطل تحكم على
بعض من بره بالطريقه دي لان محدش فينا
عارف مين بيواجه ايه او ايه هو نوع الاذى
اللي عنده او المرض اللي عنده اللي بيت
اللي هو بيحاول ان هو يتغلب
عليه ماحدش فينا عارف وماحدش فينا عارف كا
واحد من اللي قاعدين دلوقتي ممكن يكون
عنده مشكله زي دي او يعرف حد عنده مشكله
زي دي
بسش المرض هو ابتلاء من ربنا ما حدش فينا
بيختار هو مريض
بايه وايا كان الشخص بيعاني من اي مرض في
الدنيا ايا كان ايه هو فهو محتاج اللي
اكبر من الحب والتشجيع وهو ان انت تصدق
فيه تصدق فيه كشخص انه يقدر ينجز ويحقق
زيه زيك بني ادم زيه زيك ايا كان يقدر
يتغلب عليه ويقدر يقدر يعمل معجزات
وصدقوني صدقوني اليوم اللي انت بتصدق فيه
شخص بجد اتفرج وشوف المعجزات
[تصفيق]
شكرا